[Music]
in concerned racist news I'm very
concerned here submitted by come to
Toronto Toronto
I like your tower Toronto a woman called
the police on a black man who was
babysitting white kids Dave Chappelle
[ __ ] did mmm that's like some day she
fell stand worship where they would have
the [ __ ] the black family on the long
the cops would arrest him first has
anyone ever did that on Casey when his
just watching Isaac what's this Chinese
man doing with the brown baby is it kind
of like sort of a little bit you could
see similarities between the two of you
them even though they're not
blood-related with Casey and Isaac
people would come up to them and say
like all your son is so sweet or
whatever like me do they come up with
the white stick with the red tip at the
bottom Casey it is all similar looking
like Isaac I think it Casey's right here
god they look really that's crazy though
I can kind of see the demeanor changing
though like the personality and all that
cuz you know when you spend a lot of
time with someone you start absorbing
the person now honestly Casey looks I
mean Isaac looks way more like Casey
than he does his own father like he
doesn't look like he's dead I mean
that's what you want to see yeah you
have seen him yes that I know but he
looks like Mexicans look more like
Mexicans Isaac just looks like you with
boy hair compared Isaac dad to Casey who
does he look more like come on you guys
have seen anyway so this story here well
if there's a lineup of 12 Latinos point
out Isaac's dad I'm not gonna point at
you yeah I don't know people would say
they'd look alike but anyway so his name
is Corey or mr. Lewis he owns like an
after-school kind of program where he
it's like they do activities after the
kids get out of school and so he was
babysitting this little boy who was six
years old and this little girl was ten
years old and this woman they were they
went to Walmart they ate had soaked
David at Subway they got some gas but
this woman approached these wee wolf and
was they were she was like oh um like
are you guys okay like are the kids okay
and then like oh she's concerned first
who are you like yeah why wouldn't they
be okay and then she was like and then
like she kept following them and then
she approached them again she was like
can I speak to the little girl and then
he was like no why would that was wrong
away from my creepy get away pedophile
it's so funny that she so raises that
she doesn't think that she's weird art
think are the kids girls no it's a boy a
girl okay that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
yeah and then so she followed them all
the way to his house and then he parked
and then that's when he started
recording yes
you video yo this lady followed me all
the way home I got two kids that don't
look like me two beautiful kids by the
way follow me all the way home that's
now police is here now as a llama yeah I
got to babysit she pulled out to talk
about some other kids okay why wouldn't
it be okay no one's yelling no extremely
little child run away please explain to
the officer who mr. Lewis is please that
kid hella cute I know I want him to be
my son
little glasses she's tall even the cops
like my car dude if I was the top if I
was the cop I would turn around and
[ __ ] ticket her ass for being a
stalker though he talks he's probably
embarrassed you know I'll put up with it
like this dog just just to play it on
the other side it does look a little off
and you know what I mean like not
because he's black and white it's just
they just look hella different you know
what I mean yeah so I guess like you can
observe the kids like the kids look like
they're fine like they're not trying to
like there's nothing weird happening
yeah but at the same time like a lot of
these like kidnapping cases - the kids
always look fine you know what I mean so
I guess I mean she's a little weird in
that kind of but it's not like I don't
see where she's coming from
it's like cuz he's like so young and
like like the babysitter he doesn't look
like a babysitter - me either
I've seen a lot of like Latino ladies
but they're older babies like white kids
cuz I want to see like a young like this
cool-looking dude hanging out with like
a bunch of little kids and I guess
that's like maybe the concern versus
like the skin because you don't
typically see men yeah you don't see men
being babysitters and he looks like
super young yeah so it's kind of a
little weird I guess yeah but then I
think the big fellow extreme like yeah
getting somebody's business like that
I'm just playing the other side yeah it
also just shows like how sheltered she
grew up how its secure she is but I
think it's also good like in in with
kids I also believe in better safe than
sorry
yeah yeah I think that's banner that she
did call cleared it up she looks like a
[ __ ] idiot because how many other
kidnapping cases could there have been
yeah also what he could do to prevent
any other stupid-ass just calling her
well you know they have those removable
magnet things oh it could be like mr.
Lewis's daycare and there's a baby see
little wooden blocks well he did have a
shirt with his Center like the kid
Center oh I think it's also dangerous
too because like if the cop wasn't was
super paranoid and then she blew it up
like there's this man Oh with two
children you'll be like holy [ __ ]
seriously and he [ __ ] drives up on
her [ __ ] pulls a gun on them and then
you'd like wait wait wait and then you
know yeah something bad could have
happened you know good being the cop
handle it so the cop was like that [ __ ]
is crazy bro that's what was dragging
his feet I was like the first time I saw
us [ __ ] I saw you at Walmart that was
the most embarrassed cop I've ever seen
I know because he probably I saw the
situation like okay I know what's going
on and this is embarrassed how would I
want to put too much hate on the lady
though like I think she was trying to do
good and I don't think it was a it's
just a title so he's like a black man
with two white kids or just like [ __ ]
you kiddo but why people be calling the
police on everything though just
recently I [ __ ] retweeted this [ __ ]
these white kids call the police on
whales okay
yeah we're gonna talk about that we'll
talk about that so stay stay tuned but
[ __ ] man that [ __ ] was hilarious
on the ocean mammal was it like was it a
whale no no no it was like oh it was it
was a family oh you know what we're not
talking about it yeah I talk about it
right now
all right so it's a family on a boat
right and then the dads like it starts
off with the whale already underneath
the boat remember what we all went to
the shark boat and they started coming
up like yeah yeah the dad was like oh my
god this is a once-in-a-lifetime chance
and then his daughter was freaking the
[ __ ] out she's like oh my god dad oh my
god we got to leave they're gonna flip
the boat over oh my god and you like
calm down honey
calm I don't want to die today in
the other other sign and everyone was
freaking now and then she [ __ ] I
think it was his wife now cuz he kept
saying honey and I come down well I
thought it was a daughter I don't know
but you can't see who it is you just
hear them [ __ ] being hysterical and
then they actually call 9-1-1 and say
that there is a whale
there's - whale - oh my and then like
the dads like oh man like honey just
calm down this is a once in a life for
the coal or the cops going to do arrest
them like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] shoot
the whales that's so [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] call the Navy and [ __ ] and start
blowing them out of the water like Papa
bring the helicopter and the SWAT team
flies down and [ __ ] harpoons then the
seafloor and in any chief she was so
panicky that like you know he had to
turn on the engine when he had the
chance to and [ __ ] bone out but
that's super dangerous because the
propellers can scratch up the whales and
they were just curious
it was stupid dude I was like man people
pay to do this [ __ ] I know and they got
to yeah yeah I got lucky to have because
I'm gonna go whale watching
hey you don't even see a whale whoever
was doing the [ __ ] both should have
jetted the [ __ ] away a little bit though
cuz that [ __ ] can capsize you in
a second yeah yeah but that's why he was
just go you have life jackets on you
can't see anybody in them
oh there you just see the whales they're
just recording do the follows the the
respondent that picked up like I'd be in
tears laughs just be in tears dying
that's so [ __ ] funny man I understand
though on this lady's case just I really
do want to defend her because like also
I think like if she's a parent she could
tell when two kids seemed like their
that's their parent you know they have a
certain type of real you know yeah but
if the kids were quiet they're just
being respectful then it's kind of a
little odd so I just really don't think
that people should vilify her a little
bit cuz she was trying to do some good
because you know like when you're around
somebody who's like that if you guys
have just been to like after-school
programs before like when you're around
that person you don't treat them like
they're your parent
you're kind of flying you're a little
respectful so maybe that was like an odd
interaction so you know yeah I didn't
pick the wrong person yeah that's all
the daycare center t-shirt probably
would have been a good tell yeah yeah
the daycare t-shirt is like duh it what
also sucks for the cop is like we have a
friend that's a cop and he works in the
black community and it's already part of
that community to have distrust towards
cops so for them like kinda Hal you know
nurses have like bedside manner he was
explaining to us that there's like
neighborhood sideman or to like in and
when you're coming to a community where
the it's they already had that type of
oppression like it's or he could feel
the tension in the air like crazy so
like I'm pretty sure when this will got
the call he's already like [ __ ] not only
is this like this for innocent but it's
also like a black community is like [ __ ]
I got a really tiptoe around all of this
[ __ ] because how do i how do i make this
black guy believe that this white person
wasn't being prejudiced and he was just
truly caring about the kids so they have
to play a lot of like this social
balance and it's tough for cops do for
sure cuz I think him being black too is
like man this [ __ ] white lady why do
I gotta prove [ __ ] to you yeah yeah if I
had a daycare center I just keep cards
with me and if someone acts a little
weird I'll just be like you could you
could if you have children or grandkids
you know come to my business or whatever
and then I could defuse a situation but
if I'm constant like if I grew up with
constant constant like microscope yeah
people are like you [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] doing this wrong or that wrong I
just be hypersensitive about that [ __ ]
I'll be like man [ __ ] you
you're just being racist again I know
cuz like the way Corey was explaining
the situation to it I was also thinking
kind of like well you mean you could put
her mind at ease and tell her you know
like you're babysitting them but I feel
like he didn't want to give her that
satisfaction or like call me right now
cuz I'm even when the cop would say
maybe he was like my shirt says enough
like I don't know how much more have to
say yeah cuz when a cop asks for the
kids to come outside of the car so you
can talk to them Cory was like now they
have to come out like why like you're
gonna
I like her curiosity like he also didn't
want it was like his like an evil it's
also like embarrassing if you think
about it right like why do you have to
prove anything to anyone
yeah it's like when we were in high
school and it cost pull us over in life
did you steal this car get out of this
car I'm like sitting on the curb my
homies are driving by looking at like
why the [ __ ] my my knees and I'm
handcuffed they think I stole my own car
I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
cuz we weren't doing crime at that
moment I saw pictures of you guys I
would have done a citizen's arrest like
you stole everything for no reason they
want to came up to me they would have
came up to me and they'd have been like
who did I like these dudes right here
these guys right here officer I'll give
a [ __ ] dude
I had cute little glasses
[Music]